bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons ensemble le sommaire de cette
édition elle enflamme la Royal Factory
par son énergie son sourire et son
talent d'humoriste c'est la vie et notre
invité ce soir samedi dernier à quelques
minutes de monter sur la scène du
prismaï encour le compte de Bouderbala
nous raconte ses débuts de standup et sa
façon bien à lui d'écrire du 3 au 6 mars
le théâtre de Saint-Quentin en ivine
présente le Misanthrope dans une version
moderne et un poil provocatrice Nicolas
Gervet a rencontré Jean-François
Sivadier le metteur en scène notre
invité ce soir est une star au Cameroun
elle est la première femme humoriste à
avoir réussi dans son pays et elle a
choisi de venir conquérir le public
français bonsoir c'est la vie bonsoir
donc vous êtes comédienne et humoriste
et avant de parler de votre spectacle
que vous jouez donc actuellement à la
royel Factory à versaill jusqu'au 22
mars ex et bien j'aimerais que vous
évoquiez avec nous votre parcours quand
vous êtes arrivé en France puisqueque
vous êtes arrivé en
2007 après donc de nombreuses
expériences au Cameroun télé radio
vous avez écrit différents scénarios
donc un long métrage oui sur la pandémie
du sida voilà donc bon c'est un sujet
très très
sérieux et puis alors comment quand
lorsque vous êtes arrivé comment sont
passé vos premières démarches est-ce que
vous avez été accueilli facilement et
reconnu en tant qu'artiste est-ce que
vous avez rencontré des difficultés non
ça s'est pas bien passé parce que quand
je suis arrivé je je suis arrivé avec
tout l'engourment avec tous mes trucs je
suis allé au pô emploi alors j'ai dit
bon dans mon pays j'étais actrice
j'étais dans une chaîne télé j'ai montré
tous mes documents on m'a dit non vous
ici ça n'a pas de valeur je dis mais
comment ça ça n'a pas de valeur voilà je
suis comédienne je suis actrice non ça
n'a pas de valeur pourquoi parce que vos
cachets sont pas français je dis mais
l'argent n'a pas de couleur l'argent n'a
pas de nationalité c'est quoi l'histoire
de mes cachets sont pas français non
vous pouvez pas ici vous devez avir le
statut d'intermittente non voilà j'ai dû
recommencer à zéro repayer des
formations qui pouvaient pas être
subventionnées puiser sur mes économies
pour me former voilà alors justement en
parlant de formation vous avez fait une
formation pendant 3 ans oui dans une
école qui s'appelle l'école du one man
show ou à Paris euh comment ça s'est
passé qu'est-ce que vous avez appris
dans cette école et là j'ai j'ai écrit
mon
spectacle pendant 3 ans h parce que déjà
quand je suis allée quand j'ai fait des
formations dans le cinéma même après ma
formation à l'Actor Studio Jack garfen
qui était une très bonne formation j'ai
j'ai vraiment kiffé travailler avec Jack
GFEN on m'a dit enfin j'allais partout
dans les casting mais mais les rôles non
désolé le profil correspond pas il
correspond pas je dis bon au lieu de
m'emmerder à chaque fois alleer le
profil il correspond pas j'ai faire mon
one du coup je me suis inscrite à
l'école et voilà j'ai écrit mes sketch
j'ai écrit les premier sketch le truc
c'est que notre humour la façon dont
nous parlons c'est pas pareil que la
façon justement est-ce que vous avez dû
adapter vos vos sketch votre façon
d'écrire à l'humour français avec a des
codes peut-être différents de ceux que
vous connaissiez exactement il y a plein
de codes différents il y a même des
expressions différentes comme quoi par
exemple par exemple chez nous quand on
veut dire ne remets pas à demain ce que
tu peux faire tout de suite on on te dit
on ne garde pas le deuil de l'enfant et
ici quand tu dis on garde pasil
l'enfant donc il y a des trucs je
faisais je disais des trucs et ça
choquait donc j'avais pas l'intention de
choquer les des gens je disais non non
non je veux pas c'est pas par exemple le
merci du chien dit le MERCI du chien
c'est c'est le caillou ou les coups de
pied c'est comme pour dire que les gens
savent pas reconnaître des choses à leur
just valeur et tout donc c'est c'est un
peu ça j'étais confronté à tout ça et il
m'a fallu euh c'est un peu le choc des
cultures quand même exactement c'est ça
et alors vous avez fait des rencontre
quelqu'un vous a un peu guidé dans dans
dans tout ça quand j'ai terminé ma ma
formation à l'école du one man show j'ai
fait la rencontre de René Marc Gug qui
s'occupe de la chaîne ouv la scène
ouverte autant pour moi candidat tort à
Paris j'allais jouer là-bas une fois
j'ai ramené un sketch qui parlait de mon
cul ah B voilà parce que j'en avais
marre on narrêtait pas de me dire ouais
comment de dos on n'arrête pas de me
draguer quand je me retournais pardon
excusez-moi c'est vrai du coup j'ai eu
qu'un sketch sur mon queue et je suis
allé jouer la scène nouvelle il a
tellement rigolé il a trouvé que c'était
c'était osé il a dit ben écoute reviens
avec un autre sketch vous avez
travailler ensemble et oui on a commencé
à travailler ensemble même tout ce que
j'ai fait j'avais écrit écrit à l'école
on a réécr
parce qu'il y a des endroits que les
gens ne comprenaient pas bien pas parce
que c'était pas drôle parce que les
phrasesent pas bien tourné par rapport à
ma façon de parler d'accord alors votre
spectacle donc c'est un one man
show un one woman show pardon et vous
avez raison de de le préciser vous êtes
une femme effectivement donc c'est la
vie vous colonise parce que chacun son
tour c'est le nom de votre one woman
show ex ça parle de quoi ça parle de de
moi ça parle de de tout le monde de de
l'Afrique avec mon de la France avec mon
regard d'africaine de la politique du du
choc des cultures ça parle de de des
nounous de comment est-ce que vous
éduquez vos enfants et c'est parce que
chez nous par exemple on ne prend pas le
temps pour expliquer quelque chose à un
enfant on n pas le temps à perdre c'est
ça j'ai j'ai vois j'ai aller prendre mon
fils à à l'école chez des garçons et
alors la maman d' d'un copain à mon fils
il il attendait que son son enfant
finisse elle attendait autant pour moi
que son enfant finisse de sauter dans
une flaque d'eau alors je la regarde je
suis étonnée je dis mais pourquoi vous
attendez qu'il saute dans la flaque
d'eau d non il faut qu'il le fasse
maintenant sinon plus tard ce serait
tiens d'accord mais moi je pourrais
j'allais j'allait dit ben vas-y pourquoi
tu sautes dans la FR c'est comme ça que
j'ai étélevé mon papa disait souvent les
Allemands avaient dit le médicament du
noir c'est la
chicotte bon tout t' était dit alors là
était dit
c'est un peu ça que j'essaie de faire
comprendre dans mon dans mon spectacle
c'est cette comparaison entre les
cultures les attitudes différentes mais
écoutez moi je vous propose c'est qu'on
regarde un extrait de votre spectacle
d'accord c'est la
vie un bon
public je suis en France depuis 5 ans
j'ai déjà connu deux
présidents ils disent toujours qu'il a
la démocratie en Afrique mais moi j'ai
le même président depuis que je suis né
c'est comme si vous aviez toujours le
général
de au moins le bon côté des choses chez
moi c'est que ça simplifie les cours
d'histoire à
l'école depis mon enfance c'est toujours
la même histoire et c'est
normal parce que mon Président il adore
sonais depu qu'il est il n' bouge
pas en PE d'élection il va dans la ville
la plus proche il fait son petit meting
de ou TR il dans la voiture sal la comm
une princesse il ne connaî même pas la
route qui mène dans mon
village en même temps ça peut se
comprendre pour aller dans mon village
il y a pas de
route alors voilà donc c'est une
comparaison une sorte de de comparaison
est-ce que vous fait vous faites appel à
vos propres références vos propres
expériences tout est un peu inventé non
c'est c'est pas inventé c'est j'ai j'ai
remarqué quand je suis arrivée ici qu'il
y avait j'ai eu l'impression que les
gens avaient des que le président avait
des comptes à rendre aux gens c'est bien
c'est le cas oui c'est le cas et c'est
c'est bien parce que nous mais c'est on
va pas dire déjà le président le le
président ici on dit François Hollande
on dit flambille machin et ça passe à la
télé c'est pas possible c'est c'est même
pas envisageable moi je travaillais à la
télé où je je travaillais de temps en
temps je faisais la revue de presse
j'avais une émission sur la revue de
presse d'une façon comique un jour j'ai
parlé du ministre de de la communication
et d'un autre ministre le PDG m'a appelé
il a dit si la vie tu es assise ou tu es
deb je dis je suis debout assi-toi
prends un stylo tu écris il m'a cité
trois noms ne prononce plus jamais ses
nom tu veux confme ma chaîne ou quoi
donc c'est un truc comme ça ici même les
guignol à la télé il parlent des
politiques il parlent du préson attendez
venez c'est tout ça que je mets en
situation dans dans mon spectacle et
avec humour avec humour beaucoup
d'humour beaucoup d'humour parce qu'on
rit beaucoup et le public le public vous
l'avez conqui le publicement moi je je
vous ai vu le 31 décembre c'était à
Paris puisque vous avez joué dans le cas
du Big Show donc c'est un plateau avec
plusieurs humoristes et ce soir là vous
avez remporté le prix du public c'est
pas le seul puisque vous avez aussi
remporté le prix du public du festival
des blancs mananteau pour les 30 40 ans
je crois 40 ans des blan 40 ans vous
avez été sélectionné au festival de r en
cours bon vous étiez un peu malade le
soir du donc vous avez pas mené jusqu'au
bout je dirais cette cette sélection
mais voilà donc le public est vraiment
là le public vous a précis et parlons du
public justement puisque vous êtes à
Versailles en ce moment est-ce qu'il est
différent de du public parisien oui le
le public de versaill le public la Royal
Factory c'est un public qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous d'être à la Royal
Factory c'est comme son nom l'indique la
Royal factoryie c'est royal d'être
là-bas je suis tellement contente parce
que déjà à versaill une noire à
Versailles quoi je suis la première
noire à l'affiche à Versailles je me
lappète un peu non c'est c'est c'est que
du bonheur un public d'un certain âge
qui quand ils viennent ils viennent
s'amuser ils sont là pour s'amuser ils
rigolent ils se lâchent à un moment
donné dans le spectacle je fais monter
des gens on danse j'apprends des je
donne des coups de danse de chez moi à
la fin je danse aussi je dis bon je vais
danser comme les blancs je danse avec la
musique de Bouville et tout et c'est
rigolo c'est c'est bon enfant le public
versaillais c'est un super public bon
super public donc il faut pas hésiter à
vous retrouver donc à la royale Factory
c'est tous les samedis à 20h30 jusqu'au
22 mars exactement juste petite Anecd
pour finir c'est la vie alors c'est
votre nom de vie et de scène vraiment
oui c'est parce c'est quoi l'histoire en
fait c'est quand je suis né mon père il
a
dit encore une fille pourtant j'étais
que la deuxème fille sur 42 enfants 42
enfants oui il il avait plus
d'imagination mais plus d'imagination il
a dit merde ben merde ma mère elle a dit
c'est la vie mais c'est la vie chérie
heureusement ils ont gardé c'est la vie
valit mieux que que merde voilà c'est ça
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur sur notre
plateau et encore une fois et très bon
spectacle jusqu'au donc 22 mars à la
royale factctory à Versailles on va
continuer notre page humour samedi
dernier à quelques minutes de montter
sur scène le compte de Bouderbala nous
raconte ses débuts de standup et sa
façon bien à lui d'écrire on
écoute ça m'a beaucoup aidé parce que
j'ai on va dire que j'ai beaucoup
souffert là-bas sur scène parce que
c'était une école super et euh je ouais
je je dirais que 6 mois là-bas ça m'a
donné ouais 3 ans de de d'expérience en
France 4 ans parce que c'était des
contextes très compliqués dans des
petits bars face à des Américains qui
qui vous attendent pas du tout alors les
rouains quand ils peuvent pas aller
bosser ils envoient les rouaines
rouaines c'est deuxr techniques plus
l'instinct maternel c'est
bébé c'est bébé c'est bébé
B monre son fils comme si c'était le
tien mais je le connais pas cet enfant
madame ah non c'est pas mon fils non je
la quand Mme ça va tu veux me faire une
PO naref ou quoi qu'est-ce qui t'arrive
toi
bébé 1 € bébé 1 € 1 €
seulement c'est pas cher pour un
enfant pas des papiers à remplir vous
plaîti pas mais vousz d en or madame
quelle est votre méthode en fait
d'écriture bon c'est une méthode assez
assez classique
de voilà j'ai des idées qui viennent et
je trouve des décalages je me dis bah
tiens est-ce que ça ça me fait rire et
dans quel contexte je peux sortir ce ce
sujet de la de de ce qu'on y de ce qu'on
en pense en général puis après je vais
bon après j'ai des c'est des techniques
un petit peu spéciales personnelles et
assez bizarres c'est-à-dire bon sur un
sketch on peut on peut écrire un sketch
en 6 mois comme on peut l'écrire en 5
minutes ça va dépendre de l'inspiration
ça va dépendre de de la de la façon dont
on a de créer aussi de du texte ou de la
de la vanne ou de la blague c'estàdire
que parfois il a des gens qui sont dans
une frustration qui peuvent créer
beaucoup plus facilement ou au contraire
des gens qui sont dans un bien-être
total et qui voilà qui peuvent créer ces
il vous faut quoi comme
climat pour écire non moi je quand je je
suis très produc productif
pardon en frustration donc après je me
mets pas volontairement dans dans dans
ou inconsciemment en tout cas peut-être
parfois ouais c'est possible on va
s'allonger et bien si vous voulez savoir
si le compte de Bouderbala finit par
s'allonger je vous propose de regarder
l'intégralité de cette interview sur
notre site internet
wwwtvfil78.com rubrique reportage et si
vous ne l'avez pas encore vu sur scène
vous pouvez le retrouver le 4 mars à la
salle jacqubrê à Montini et maintenant
retrouvons sans plus attendre Nicolas
Gervet pour sa chronique dans le
kiosque il nous présente son misanthrope
du 3 au 6 mars au Théâtre de
SaintQuentin en Yveline un misanthrope
inspiré un poil décalé un poil rock and
roll et au poil voici Jean-François
civadier dans le
kiosque comme l'on m'a dit que vous
étiez ici j'ai monté pour vous dire et
d'un cœur véritable que j'ai conçu pour
vous une estime
incroyable j'ai relu cette pièce il y a
pas longtemps j'ai j'ai trouvé qu'elle
était extrêmement forte et que les idées
que j'avais dessus étaient un peu des
des préjugés et que c'est une pièce qui
au moins aussi forte que Tartu fait
don qui elle me semblait très
actuelle intemporel
universel
on a mis une chanson des Clash au début
de la représentation on voulait que
alest il commence la représentation par
un acte très
fort un acte anarchique
euh voilà et on a on a trouvé cette
cette chanson d'clage le ciel ne m'a
point fait on me donneant le jour une
âme compatible avec l'air de la cour je
ne me trouve point les vertus
nécessaires pour y bien réussir et faire
mes affaires être franc et sincère est
mon plus grand talent
je ne sais point jouer les hommes en
parlant et qui n'a pas le don de cacher
ce qu'il pense doit faire en ce pays
fort peu de résidence Alcest est un
rebelle il veut être un rebelle mais
c'est quand même un petit marquis
c'estàd que le le génie de Molière c'est
d'avoir montrer quelqu'un qui qui refuse
le monde mais qui fait partie du monde
qui refuse l'hypocrisie de la cour mais
qui lui-même fait partie de la cour qui
a besoin d'être dans dans dans ces
petits cercles de petits marquis pour
exister qui qui est dans un mouvement
totalement paradoxal puisquil n'arrête
pas de dire qu'il va partir qui reste au
centre du plateau parce qu'il veut qu'on
le distingue il veut qu'on le remarque
il veut être le plus intéressant parce
que sil part s'il s'exclut réellement du
monde alors il ne pourra plus parler
contre le monde al ce qu'il veut al
c'est parler c'est prendre la parole
c'est rester pour dire à quel point il a
décidé de partir le génie de Molière
c'est d'avoir rendu alest amour amoureux
d'une coquette c'est l'humaine qui
représente le le pire exemple de
duplicité voilà on peut tous ressembler
à alscest dans notre vie de tous les
jours c'est-à-dire refuser le
monde qui nous entoure refuser les les
contraintes refuser voilà
l'hypocrisie du monde de la politique de
voil et pourtant on fait on ne fuit pas
on reste là et on s'accommode euh
on s'accommode de notre vie sociale
sinon à la jungle faut-il qu'on joigne à
tant de grâce les vices odieux des âmes
les plus basses mais encore qui vous
tout est ruiné je suis je suis trahi je
suis
assassinéon pu croire cette
nouvelle me trompe et n qu'une infidèle
la priorité c'est de faire en sorte que
ce qu'on voit rarement à mon
avis dans le Misanthrope c'est deux
choses
c'est d'une part que on a le droit
d'être contre Alcest de pas être
d'accord avec lui Alcest il est pas un
héros on a le droit d'être d'accord et
on a le droit d'être d'être contre lui
tout le
temps parce qu'Alcest voilà et que alest
et filind sont deux parties de
nous-mêmes de force égale le refus de la
ou l'accommodement au jeux social que
vous semble
d' quel orgueil extrême c'est un homme
gonflé de l'amour de soi-même son mérite
jamais n'est content de la cour contre
elle il fait métier de pester chaque
jour et ne donne emploi charge ni
bénéfice qu'à tout ceux qu' se croi on
ne fasse
injustice les acteurs ont vraiment la
conscience d'être regardés par le par un
public
et que évidemment quand alest dit enfin
s'adresse au monde dans la première
scène c'est vraiment les gens qui sont
qui sont dans la salle dont il parlent
c'est
une des rares pièces de Molière
peut-être même la seule où c'est rare
d'ailleurs au théâtre que le le le
public n'a pas un métro d'avance sur les
personnages les personnages pareil c'est
que tout le monde est en train de de
découvrir la pièce au fur et à mesure et
qui
a il y a une chose très forte sur le
rapport au au présent c'estàd qu'on peut
rien deviner de ce qui va arriver c'est
une pièce où il se passe absolument rien
c'est ça qui est génial évidemment à
partir du moment où on accepte qu'il se
passe rien c'est là qu'il commence à se
passer énormément de choses l'honneur de
contredire a pour lui tant de charmes
qu'il prend contre lui-même assez
souvent les armes et ses vrais
sentiments sont combattus par lui
aussitôt qu'on les voit dans la bouche
d'autruie
les décors les
costumes moi au théâtre j'aime bien par
exemple si je monte un classique le
Misanthrope j'aime bien faire se frotter
deux époques
sur sur le plateau c'est le le 17e en
l'occurrence et puis et puis aujourd'hui
quoi donc il y a il y a une rêverie sur
le 17e on s'amuse beaucoup
avec avec l'idée de Versailles
de de la représentation
de
de de l'élégance de de du souci de
l'élégance de la coquetterie de voilà il
y a un jeu avec le le 1e et puis aussi
en frottement avec aujourd'hui quoi en
bonne foi cro tu sans'éblouir les yeux
avoir de grands sujets de paraître
joyeux par bleu je ne vois pas lorsque
je m'examine ou prendre aucun sujet
d'avoir l'âme chagrine j'ai du bien je
suis jeune et sors d'une maison qui se
peut dire noble avec quelques raison et
je crois par le rang que me donne ma
race qu'il est fort peu d'emploi dont je
ne sois en
passe et voici pour le misanthrope de
Jean-François civadier et maintenant on
retrouve la philanthrope de la culture
ça ne veut rien dire mais on retrouve
Aurélia nous sommes mercredi c'est donc
l'heure des sorties ciné au micro
d'éodie
moine à mon avis c'est quand même moins
surprenant que le premier on rit il y a
que la fin qui est un
peu qui est pas terrible quoi mais sinon
dans le dans le film il y a des moments
très très drôles il y a beaucoup de
d'humour il y a beaucoup de jeux de mots
on s bien amusé quand
même un bon film très bien ça a bien
repris la suite du premier donc voilà et
satisfait d'être allé le voir on se Mar
enfin on rigole bien du début jusqu'à la
fin voilà on a bien ri c'était bien une
très belle histoire
émouvante qui m'a parfois été chaleureux
bah c'est un super compte un peu
modernisé mais c'est bien disons que
pour les enfants de moins de 10 ans
c'est ça ferait peut-être un peu il
serait peut-être impressionné quand même
c'est tellement réaliste que voilà
l'istoire était très belle c'était
vraiment quelque chose de fantastique de
pouvoir le voir c'est un beau film un
peu lent mais très très beau film très
belle poésie beaucoup de poésie et
vraiment un super film j'ai bien aimé
mais un peu long quand même j'aurais
voulu avoir un peu plus d'action et voir
alors cette semaine nous vous proposons
d'écouter Luc bequan directeur du ciné7
à hencour nous donner son coup de cœur
mon coup de cœur cette semaine c'est le
dernier film de Ayo Miyazaki qui est
d'ailleurs le dernier tout dernier puis
qu'il a annoncé à 72 ans qui l' arrêtait
après c'est bien dommage et c'est le
vent se lève c'est un film d'animation
évidemment japonais qui dure 2h6 et qui
est absolument sublime et qui raconte la
vie enfin un passage de la vie de girud
qui a toujours rêver de voler de faire
voler des engins qui va en inventer
jusqu'à créer malheureusement le célèbre
zéro qui a servi pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale tout ça sur fond de
paysage absolument splendide et de
dessins absolument splendide de Miyasaki
je rappelle qu' travaille à la main et
cetera et cetera voilà donc c'est à voir
vraiment surtout c'est son dernier film
sur nos écrans cette semaine mais pas
que chez
nous je vous propose à présent quelques
idées de sortie ces prochains jours
alors tout d'abord dans le cadre de
l'exposition sur les 30 ans des cultures
urbaines que nous fêons notamment sur ce
sur le territoire le musée de la ville
organise une rencontre samedi à 15h avec
les acteur de la culture street d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui loin des clichés ils
vous feront découvrir leur univers et
leurs valeurs si vous souhaitez vous
pouvez également assister à un concert
celui du Saint-Quentin gospel ce sera
samedi à 20h30 au scarabé à La Verrière
notre édition est à présent terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi sur
TVF et je vous retrouve donc la semaine
prochaine en direct à 18h30 bonne
soirée